- Yeah mom, I'm
really digging it.
Yeah, no it's fun,
it's nice out.
No I haven't joined a gang,
I don't think I'll do that.
Rick's good, yeah.
Yeah, he's soberish.
Yeah, my knees holding
out, oh, okay, I'll talk
to you later mom.
Bye, I love you.
- Comedy open mic
tomorrow night,
come check it out or try it out.
First timers get on for sure.
- Well I won't be trying it
out, I'm a dramatic actor,
I just moved to town.
Very very serious stuff.
- Okay, so Robin Williams,
Jim Carrey and Jamie Foxx
never did both?
Wake up man, expand
your range bro.
- Yeah, good point.
- Come back and
expand that range bro.
(rap music)
- I thought you were going
to be a dramatic actor.
- It's called range bro.
Look at Jim Carrey,
Robin Williams,
Academy Award winner Jamie Foxx.
They all had it dude,
I could do that.
I was class clown.
- No you weren't,
- Rick, you weren't in class,
you were a parking lot clown.
- Of course I'm gonna be there
bro, you're gonna kill it.
I got you.
- Thanks man.
- Does open mic mean open bar?
- No
- Oh
- So I was riding in
a cab the other day
and I was super high right
and the cab driver asked me,
"Where you going?"
And I start talking
like Matthew McConaughey
and so I respond,
"Alright, alright,
"alright"
(laughs)
- That dude's hilarious.
Good luck following that shit.
- How many beers have you had?
- Six, but I did a bub
of coke in the bathroom
so I'm good.
- Great. Look man, maybe
this was a bad idea.
- What? Dude we came all
the way down here together.
You got this.
- I know, it's just I
overheard that those guys
in the suits are big agents.
- So he looks kinda
Chinese though.
- That's the dud I did
coke with in the bathroom!
- You guys ready
for your next comic?
This guy is new to town,
he wants to be an actor.
Give it up for Gary Scouser.
- You got this buddy,
eye of the tiger.
I'll be in the crowd
supporting you.
- Okay, I got it.
Feel better
(scattered applause)
Hey everybody, how are ya?
That's a warm welcome.
Let's get started.
Yeah, my name is Gary,
I'm new to Los Angeles
and traffic is not great,
we all know that.
I'm not used to it yet.
(boos)
(nervous chuckle)
Yeah, (stutters)
- Oh wow, great material,
let me guess, airplane
food is so bad.
(laughs)
- Rick.
- Hey, nice haircut.
What time is the barbecue
in Ohio, you fucking Dork.
(laughs)
(stutters)
Hey, nice gut.
What Dunkin Donuts
you work out at?
(laughs)
- Yeah, why don't you get AIDS.
(audience gasps)
(boos)
- I have AIDS.
- Are you alright?
You'll never get an agent
in this fucking town.
- I didn't know--
(slow clap)
- Alright, that
was Gary everybody.
- Oh my God.
- Ah there he is,
dude you killed--
- What in the fuck
are you doing?
Why did you heckle me?
- What do you mean?
I came for support
just like I said.
I got your back
dude, we're a duo.
You know, like how
we are in real life.
- You didn't let me get
out a joke, not one joke.
They fucking booed me and then
the agents walked out angry.
Great!
- Yeah, you made
fun of their AIDS.
- I didn't fucking,
I don't even know
if they have AIDS.
I just blurted it out.
That's a horrible thing to say
about anybody if they do or
they don't have fucking AUDS.
- You should just
calm down, relax bro,
it's gonna be okay.
Listen, you're a dramatic actor.
Comedy isn't easy dude,
it's just not your thing.
- I wouldn't know that because
I couldn't get out one joke
so I don't know that.
- Sorry bro my bad.
Let's just go get a drink
and forget about how terrible
that was okay?
- You said it was fine though.
- Hey, sorry to interrupt,
that was so great.
You were so funny in there.
- Thanks man I mean--
- No, no, no not
you, your friend.
What's you name man?
- Rick.
- You were hysterical, you're
my new favorite comedian.
- Oh, thank you.
- Boo!
(trap music)